[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu passei pelo menos uns 30 anos da
minha vida e quero ajudar a buscar
experiências bem sucedidas na educação
no brasil
para inspirar a nossa vocação para
tentar responder e que são fundamentais
para que nós possamos mudar essa relação
é sempre um problema um momento fácil e
tudo desde problema eu tive uma falha
que ia ser legal a informação dos
médicos e dos meus pais foi de que eles
deviam ser tentada teve uma vida de
muitos desafios
provavelmente dificuldade de falar em
obstrução e certamente dificuldades e as
outras sequelas e os pais teriam que
ajudar os médicos a descobrir
foi assim que quando chegou à fase que
eu deveria começar a andar
meus pais descobriram uma sequela muito
forte nos membros inferiores
eu comecei uma série de cirurgias e
passei a minha primeira infância toda
entre cirurgias e por isso não pude para
educação infantil
eu entrei na escola direto no primeiro
ano o ano letivo já começado
naquele momento tanto os médicos quanto
os meus pais perceberam que a fala e
audição não haviam sido afetadas
eu entrei na escola com esforço muito
grande dos meus pais para que a escola
me aceitasse a primeira escola disse não
ela não vai conseguir acompanhar meus
pais foram em uma próxima escola e
prometeram que eles vão ajudar no que
fosse preciso se a escola me aceitasse
e foi assim que duas coisas aconteceram
primeiro eu me apaixonei pela escola que
eu amava e pra aula ea segunda foi que
para surpresa de todos
muito rapidamente eu tirei a defasagem
que eu tinha em relação aos meus colegas
de classe que tinham feito educação
infantil e que tinham começado o ano
letivo desde o início daquele ponto em
diante da minha vida eu sempre fui a
melhor aluna da sala
decidi que eu queria para a área de
educação porque eu queria muito devolver
para a educação a oportunidade que ela
me deu nesse dia que eu queria fazer
letras porque eu sempre me gramática
língua portuguesa literatura mas o meio
do meu trajecto no ensino fundamental
o professor chamou meu pai quando eu
cheguei no 5º ano e disse que eu tinha
muita facilidade para aprender a língua
inglesa e perguntou para os meus pais eu
tinha alguém casa que estava me ajudando
meu pai no pedreiro ea mãe era uma dona
de casa ea língua inglesa nunca tinha
nem passado perto de casa quando meu pai
ouviu isso na escola ele saiu e foi
atrás de vários cursos de línguas até
que ele achou um que aceitou a proposta
dele que foi trocar serviços de
manutenção pelo curso de inglês pra mim
era só assim que meu pai podia pagar com
o trabalho que ele fazia
em virtude disso quando eu entrei na
faculdade de letras ou 17 anos eu já
falava inglês e quando eu terminei a
faculdade eu ganhei uma bolsa pra fazer
uma especialização na inglaterra quando
voltei para o brasil eu fui trabalhar
coordenando algumas unidades de ensino
de línguas e fui convidada para corrigir
as provas de mestrado e doutorado de
inglês de uma das primeiras
universidades do brasil a receber
internet de alta velocidade
quando eu vi a internet a universidade o
computador na escola tive uma ideia e
juntei toda essa tecnologia para ajudar
a melhorar o ensino de línguas a
proporcionar que mais alunos tivessem
acesso ao ensino do inglês
isso gerou uma reportagem dois grandes
jornais de estados diferentes do brasil
e essas reportagens combinaram com
vídeo que eu recebi para trabalhar numa
empresa que estava chegando no brasil
com a proposta de fazer a integração da
tecnologia em todas as áreas do
conhecimento
eu entrei nessa empresa como assistente
pedagógica e fiz todo um caminho até que
me tornei vice presidente desta empresa
estava em 89 países e eu comecei a
viajar para as convenções internacionais
e para buscar respostas nos países que
terá melhor qualidade da educação no
mundo de como nós poderíamos conseguir
envolver os alunos ajudar o professor a
lidar com essa frustração tão grande de
preparar uma aula e chega animado e
embora triste porque não conseguia
envolver o aluno quanto mais eu conhecia
escolas modelo mas buscava inspiração e
vinha pro brasil implantar os projetos
então depois de algum tempo apesar do
não vai ouvir não vai falar não vai
aprender
eu estava ali profissionalmente muito
realizada cumprindo a minha missão na
área de educação então chegou a hora que
bateu a vontade de realizar meu sonho de
vida que era ser mãe e quando eu
decidirei tava na hora de realizar esse
sonho eu recebi a informação de que eu
não ia poder realizar o sonho de gerar o
filho pelas sequelas que eu ainda tenho
da paralisia cerebral eu não teria
problema para engravidar mas não
conseguiria levar uma gestação até o
final
eu levei um tempo processando essa
informação mas um dia eu pensei o
seguinte essa mesma pessoa a que a
medicina está dizendo que não vai ser
possível realizar o sonho de gerar um
filho também foi a pessoa para quem um
dia disseram não vai andar não vai falar
não vai aprender e eu estava lhe fazendo
tudo isso então eu decidi que ia tentar
realizar o sonho de ser mãe eu
engravidei e do quinto mês em diante eu
entendi o que os médicos estavam
tentando me dizer
e eu tive realmente uma gravidez muito
complicado de altíssimo risco
quatro meses de repouso absoluto e no
dia 30 de junho de 1989
o meu sonho maior se realizou minha
filha nasceu forte saudável e passou a
me acompanhar na minha missão na
educação então toda vez que ela estava
de férias na escola ela ia junto comigo
para o país que eu fosse da cidade do
brasil que eu fosse trabalhar na
educação ela estava junto comigo toda
vez que ela estava de férias quando
chegou a hora de a lei pra faculdade que
a minha felicidade
ela se formou em pedagogia na usp quando
ela saiu da faculdade ela teve uma idéia
de ajudar as famílias que tanto nos
pediam guia soluções e ideias para
conseguir que os filhos se envolvesse
com a educação então ela começou um
projeto de na casa da família e ajudar a
fazer os ajustes para que as crianças se
envolvesse mais com os estudos
e toda vez que ela ia atender uma
família ela me ligava onde quer que
estivesse e pedir ajuda e nós
descobrimos que toda vez que nós
planejávamos juntas o que a família
fazer o sucesso era muito grande
aquele aluno criança ou adolescente
consegui estudar conseguia ter um
desempenho o envolvimento com a
aprendizagem que é o que a gente mais
sonha então ela me fez um convite para
trabalhar com ela
e foi assim que eu cheguei na empresa
onde eu estava há 18 anos e cinco meses
que tinha construído uma carreira que
tinha superado vários momentos de
preconceito porque eu sou mulher porque
eu sou deficiente não dentro da empresa
no mercado eu fui lá e pedir demissão
muitas pessoas acharam que estava
ficando maluca de abrir mão de uma
carreira que eu construí com tanto suor
mas eu sabia que eu estava fazendo eu
tinha duas motivações principais uma
momento que minha filha me chamou para
trabalhar com ela eu vi diante dos meus
olhos
o meu sonho de vida se juntar com a
missão de vida a minha filha na educação
me convidando para trabalhar com ela
essa foi a primeira motivação ea segunda
foi o desejo que eu tinha de descobrir
se a medicina tinha errado quando disse
que eu teria dificuldade de aprendizagem
ou se este diagnóstico foi correto o que
teria me permitido superar esse desafio
neste momento
thaise eu minha filha nós fomos estudar
neurociência cognitiva para descobrir o
que acontece no cérebro momento de
aprendizagem e talvez achar resposta pra
mim
encontramos a neurociência descobertas
maravilhosas que trazem luz das questões
que os professores enfrentam todo dia na
sala de aula que os pais enfrentam em
casa quando o filho não quer estudar não
quer ir para a escola e para os desafios
que os nossos alunos hoje enfrentam
quando não conseguem prestar atenção
focar ter o desejo ea chama continuada
por aprender
conseguimos levar para os pais a
informação de que toda criança precisa
de uma responsabilidade compartilhada
dentro de casa
senão ela não vai desenvolver a paixão
pelos estudos
uma criança que ouvi dos pais a vida
toda
meu filho só única obrigação é estudar o
resto eu cuido não desenvolve o senso de
responsabilidade
autoestima memórias de procedimento e de
fatos para que ela consiga ter uma
relação positiva com a aprendizagem e eu
descobri que eu sou a prova viva de uma
das descobertas mais recentes da
neurociência que a neuroplasticidade a
neuroplasticidade é a capacidade do
cérebro se reestruturar se recompor
em qualquer fase da vida especialmente
durante a infância e adolescência
o ambiente rico em estímulos é capaz de
fazer com que o cérebro se regenere e
jerry comportamentos sociais cognitivas
e motores que jamais teriam acontecido
se esse aluno ou se esse filho não fosse
exposto há desafios a elogios à crença
de que ele é capaz eu descobrir que a
forma como meus pais me educaram fez de
mim a pessoa que eu sou
meus pais saíram da maternidade
decididos que eles vão focar no meu
potencial e não da minha deficiência
quando ele me levou para a escola pela
primeira vez eu ainda andava com muita
dificuldade estava recém saída de várias
cirurgias e usava uma bota muito
estranha e quando ele passava comigo na
rua de mão dada às pessoas e
acompanhando e olhando quando tinha
crianças vezes a criança apontava toda
vez que isso acontecia o meu pai olhava
pra mim e falava
eles estão achando lindo seu vestido ou
eles estão adorando a sua bota
eu acreditava tanto nisso que eu lhe o
pescoço falava deixou caprichado
quando meu pai no natal daquele tempo em
que os pais compravam um presente a
todos os filhos eles se sentiam felizes
por essa conquista e os filhos também
meu pai comprou uma bicicleta de
presente para nós quatro nós somos em
quatro irmãos desde não sabe abrir uma
bicicleta e correram para a rua andar
eu olhei pro meu pai e falei assim eu
também quero andar de bicicleta e meu
pai falou assim para mim então você vai
lá fora e pede ajuda para os seus irmãos
se eles não conseguirem de ajudar você
volta aqui que eu vou lá e vou te ajudar
o que eu me lembro é do meu irmão e
sentando na bicicleta
a minha irmã mais velha me segurando o
meu irmão caçula empurrando e eu juro
pra vocês que eu tenho a memória de que
eu andei de bicicleta mas do que essas
atitudes e posturas dos meus pais
eu tive a sorte de que a escola que me
aceitou embora nunca tivesse ouvido
falar do termo inclusão porque isso não
existe ainda a escola realmente me
incluiu todos os professores realmente
me aceitaram como uma aluna capaz de
aprender nem mesmo dá aula de educação
física eu fui dispensada a minha
professora falava assim pra mim
roberta eu preciso de ajuda para arrumar
os equipamentos e os jogos enquanto os
seus colegas correm ao redor da quadra
você pode me ajudar eu ajudava feliz da
vida cheia de orgulho quando terminava
ela falava assim a última volta eu quero
que seja caminhando na quadra e os seus
colegas estão esperando eu ia eu chegava
a atividade junto com os meus amigos e
eu me sentia parte daquele grupo e eu me
sentia parte daquela aula e eu me sentia
capaz de aprender e o que eu descobri na
neurociência cognitiva foi que a
neuroplasticidade é um processo que
acontece quando um pai fala para o filho
meu filho vai lá e tenta eu sei que você
é capaz quando o professor fala para o
aluno se você não conseguir é de ajuda
eu vou ajudar você
quando o professor chega para o aluno e
fala assim se você não conseguiu fazer
dessa forma deve ter uma outra maneira
que juntos nós podemos conseguir
e à neurociência cognitiva mostrou que a
expectativa positiva que um pai passa
pelo seu filho em relação à capacidade
que ele tem de superar os desafios
muda o cérebro fisicamente a expectativa
positiva que vocês professores passam
para os seus alunos todos os dias
é isso que o seu aluno vai levar para o
resto da vida
muito mais do que o conteúdo que você
precisa ensinar ele precisa que você
mostre pra ele que você acredita que ele
é capaz e juntos vocês vão achar o
caminho para que cada um aprenda do seu
ritmo
desenvolva o seu potencial máximo
então a resposta que eu fui procurar em
tantos países diferentes do mundo já
tinha sido me dado já tinha sido trazida
para mim por um pedreiro por uma dona de
casa
um pedreiro que seja até o 3º ano da
escola
a minha mãe que seja até o 5º ano e os
professores que nunca tinham ouvido
falar de inclusão mas realmente me
tornaram a mãe que eu sou hoje
a professora que eu fui a vida toda a
profissional que eu consegui ser e essa
pessoa que hoje
humildemente vem agradecer a todos os
pais e professores que realmente são
capazes de fazer com que a educação
humud com que os alunos realmente
descubram o prazer em aprender
obrigada
[Aplausos]